foreign
[Music]
you know people just say oh I want to be
over covet but unfortunately that's not
how it works scientifically uh it also
is exacerbated by the fact that you know
Chinese people see uh pictures or you
know foreign areas and they hear from
their friends that you can walk around
any major city in the world
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go in Foxton they tried this to
keep everything internal basically they
would just keep everybody in the factory
separate from everybody else hoping to
avoid any kind of infection it didn't
necessarily work
foreign
[Music]
is hurting the economy and the question
is how you deal with it I mean it's fine
to say well just let's put money before
people but that doesn't work as well
when you're talking about a socialist
Nation they really say we have a duty to
protect the people and to do the best we
can the question is how do you thread
that needle what
um what kind of restrictions are
necessary to protect people and still
allow the economy to go on
foreign
[Music]